wie wäre es wenn wir dieses video mit
einem kleinen experiment beginnen einmal
diese zwei worte
donald trump was kommt dabei heraus ganz
sicher bekommst du einen haufen
ergebnisse zu seinem neuesten aufreger
treat einem coolen spruch oder einem
neuen sexskandal aber du musst dich
wahrscheinlich bis auf die zweite oder
dritte seite durch klicken um etwas über
eine seiner größten politischen betten
überhaupt zu finden
wir sprechen über eine wette welche die
globale wirtschaft der ölpreis und das
schicksal zweier länder total verändern
könnte ja liebe zuschauer
die rede ist von der installationen
gegen den iran es handelt sich um eine
so komplexe thematik dass wir dieser
nicht nur ein oder zwei sondern ganze
drei videos werden um alle fragen und
fragen beantworten zu wollen
im heutigen video konzentrieren wir uns
auf die frage was hat das atomprogramm
mit dem ölpreis zu tun
am ende dieses videos wirst du genau
verstehen was ich damit meine
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie bei jeder guten geschichte sollten
wir mit der vorstellung der
protagonisten beginnen der erste ist
natürlich die islamische republik iran
ein land das für persönliche teppiche am
rande anreicherung und erdöl bekannt ist
[Musik]
ja auf diesen unseren planeten verfügte
er an über das viertgrößte vorkommen und
dino saft überhaupt aber das war noch
lange nicht alles falls er wieso politik
schon lange abonniert habt wisst ihr
bereits dass es verschiedene arten von
heute
wenn man zum beispiel ein passant öl aus
der nordsee
in der nähe von stadt land fördern
möchte muss man dazu eine teure
ölbohrplattform bauen ein loch ganz tief
unter dem meeresboden horn und eine
hightech afrika die verarbeitung braucht
man auch insgesamt kommt man damit auch
förderkosten von mehr als 44 dollar im
iran liegen die kosten für die förderung
der selben menge bei weniger als einem
viertel dessen zusammen mit saudi
arabien hat er das billigste auf diesem
planeten welches problem haben die
iraner also
sie können die meisten länder der welt
etwas nicht kaufen
die iranische wirtschaft ist praktisch
vom rest der welt abgeschnitten
aus diesem grund kann der iran nur etwa
drei millionen barrel erdöl pro tag
exportieren wo er im rahmen der sanktion
eigentlich nur etwa eine million us
daten dürfte das klingt nach einer menge
aber es ist nichts gegen die 7,5
millionen barrel pro tag begeistert von
saudi arabien exportiert werden welches
derzeit insgesamt sogar fast elf
millionen barrel pro tag produziert
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht wer ist
der ärgste feind des era ja ich weiß was
du denkst
die s bahn
nun du liegst falsch erzfeind des iran
ist eigentlich saudi arabien ja ich weiß
beide sind islamische länder sie
verfolgen strengreligiöse prinzipien und
betrachten menschenrechte als nicht
gerade verbindlich aber der islam ist
nun mal alles andere als gut im iran
stellen schiitische muslime die mehrheit
während saudi arabien ein von
sunnitischen moslems dominiere das land
ist und vereinfacht gesagt diese beiden
fraktionen sind sich spinnefeind
das aber ist eine andere geschichte die
ein eigenes video verdient was also ist
saudi arabiens problem nun trotz
ölreichtum und sticken geld sehen steht
dessen wirtschaft am rande des
zusammenbruchs im grunde genommen
verschleudert das land sein ganzes geld
wie ein drogenabhängiger rockstar und da
sie nichts anderes als erdöl exportieren
schaltet ihre wirtschaft jedes mal in
den panik modus sobald der öl preis für
ein barrel auf dem ölmarkt feld
[Musik]
jetzt fragt ihr euch vielleicht er ist
der beste freund saudi arabien nun erst
kommt amerika ins spiel
[Musik]
die liebesbeziehung zwischen regime und
dem saudischen königshaus ist nicht ganz
so himmel schießt von außen aussehen mag
die obama regierung unter druck auf die
saudis aus und versuchte mit dem iran
anzubandeln so kam das nuclear zustande
jetzt aber heißt der präsident im weißen
haus dort trank und in dem moment also
das openoffice betrat machte tom klar
wer sein verbündeter im nahen osten ist
deshalb flog er auf seiner ersten
offiziellen auslandsreise nach riad in
die hauptstadt saudi-arabiens und sogar
jetzt nach der tötung eines saudischen
dissidenten und journalisten durch
saudische agenten in der türkei versucht
eine scharfe verurteilung des audis zu
vermeiden aber der beste beweis für
seine freundschaft mit dem königshaus
ist die wiederbelebung der nuklear
sanktionen geben ja du hast richtig und
jetzt fragst du dich vielleicht was hat
saudi arabien mit den sanktionen gegen
den iran zu tun
welche rolle spielt dabei dass apple
heute werden wir alle diese fragen
beantworten aber bevor wir das tun
lassen immer einen blick in die
geschichte
eine politische bombe merkt euch dieses
datum april 2015 zu diesem zeitpunkt
unterzeichnete obama das iranische atom-
kommen im wesentlichen vereinbarten
amerika china russland und die
europäische union diesen abkommen das
sie mit dem iran handel treiben würde
wenn dieser sein atombomben programm
einstellen würden dies erklärt warum
sich die iranischen erdölexporte
daraufhin von einem tag auf den anderen
fast verdoppelt sie dir einfach mal
diese kabine
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vor obamas viel exportiert er angeblich
1,8 millionen
nachdem die stieg der export des iran
auf bis zu drei millionen barrel pro tag
die neuen kunden waren spanien
frankreich und anderen europäischen
ländern und was passiert wenn das
angebot am erdöl auf dem internationalen
markt steigt nun der preis pro barrel
sinkt das sehen wir in dieser tempel
[Musik]
zum zeitpunkt der vertragsunterzeichnung
kostete ein fass der ölsorte brent 67
usd
ein jahr später nur noch die hälfte
natürlich gibt es viele andere faktoren
die diesen preis noch mal erklären
können aber der iran war definitiv eine
rege wichtiger faktor gut jetzt pass
aber ein augenblick aussehen das war
erst der anfang der entwicklung
langjährige visuelle nötig abonnenten
wissen bereits wie schwer es ist erdöl
zu fördern
du brauchst eine menge spezieller
technik gut organisierte
unternehmensstrukturen und vor allem
geld mit anderen worten wenn die
national iranian oil company kurz nfc
müll produzieren möchte roxy investor
und zu just diesem zeitpunkt wurde die
eigentliche verzögerte
[Musik]
saudi arabien erwägt einen börsengang
von aramco dem wohl wertvollsten
unternehmen der welt
[Musik]
lasst uns hier einen moment innehalten
warum ist diese nachricht so wichtig ok
spulen wir die geschichte nochmal ein
wenig zurück
[Musik]
die finanz okay jetzt eine kleine
aufmerksamkeit frage was ist das größte
unternehmen der welt
was denkt ihr apple amazon landrat
gesagt eine band mein manko
saudi-arabiens nationale ölgesellschaft
aus dem nur weil man das größte
unternehmen der welt ist bedeutet es
nicht dass man nicht pleitegehen kann
auch der ölpreis sinkt falls der ölpreis
sinkt kann saudi arabien in eine ernste
notlage geraten aus diesem grund muss
das land seine wirtschaft dringend
diversifizieren und lernen geld auf
andere weise als mit erdöl zu verdienen
und wie zieht man so eine
diversifikation am besten durch ganz
einfach mal legt erstmal einen
hedgefonds auf saudi arabien will einen
zwei billionen dollar schweren megafon
aufbauen
mit anderen worten die saudische
regierung möchte viel geld in andere
unternehmen investieren so seltsam es
auch scheint dies ist das erste mal dass
ein ganzes land in unternehmen
investiert der weltweit größte
hedgefonds gehört nämlich keinen anderen
als der norwegischen regierung die mit
seiner helfen ihre behandlung weltweit
ist audis wohl so etwas ähnliches machen
mit problem
sie brauchen erstmal das geld ja woher
nehmen wenn nicht stehlen ganz easy
wenn man das größte unternehmen der welt
sein eigen nennt muss man einfach nur
und prozent davon an der börse verkaufen
und schon hat man grün eben zumindest
ihr auf diese weise durch das erzeugen
eines gewaltigen geld jobs in richtung
riad würde die saudische königsfamilie
zwei fliegen mit einer klappe schlagen
zum einen selbst eine menge geld
einsacken und zum anderen die investoren
davon abhalten genau dieses geld dem
iran
der erzfeind zu investieren kommen wir
nun also zum iran zurück erinnert ihr
euch als ich euch davon erzählt habe
dass der iran im jahr 2016 auf der suche
nach investoren die den bau neuer
ölförderanlagen war nun vor diesen das
grün regiert
jana plan hören wie saudi-arabien kommt
eine noch größere verfügung vor ihren
nasen bauen aramco
jetzt warte aber noch einen mann denn so
einfach war es nun das
ein unternehmen an die börse zu bringen
ist eine tolle sache weil man plötzlich
viel geld bekommt aber es gibt ein
problem bei der mann muss nun die
möglichkeit bekommen die bilanzen dieser
firma einzusehen
niemand würde aktien eines unternehmens
kaufen wenn er nicht genau wüsste wie
viel geld es bereits verdient hat und
wofür es verwendet werden mit anderen
worten transparenz ist nun transparenz
ist aber dass wohl ziemlich am wenigsten
beliebt award des saudischen
königshauses seit jahrzehnten nutzen die
saudischen monarchie aramco für all jene
dinge nach denen ihnen gerade die luft
steht partys und jede art von ausgaben
von denen möglichst niemand etwas
erfahren soll
aber das ist nicht das einzige problem
des audis laut prinz muhammad bin salman
auch bekannt als endres ist halo 2
billionen dollar wert das bedeutet dass
ihre fünf prozent der an den mann
bringen will
100 milliarden wert wären als er jedoch
anträgen bei den börsen haben zu
sprechen dann allen diese bösen den
analysten damit ihre eigenen schätzungen
anzustellen und ihr urteil war 2
billionen dollar bei den derzeitigen
verfall des ölpreises prince2 haram co
könnte 1,2 millionen wert sein
op 1,5 wenn wir äußerst großzügig sind
aber mehr ist einfach nicht sein alter
mit anderen worten der bomben börsengang
den sich abendgruß schon vorgestellt
hatte war plötzlich nur noch ein fitness
und wenn man zahlmann während des
vergangenen jahres danach gefragt wurde
habe nichts besseres aus seinem munde
als naja man ja wir müssen das machen
aber vielleicht in einem anderen tag
schon mal da bin ich irgendwie
beschäftigt diese woche und ich so viel
zu erledigen du hast schon bald habe ich
das zeug nicht auf sie warten
aber dann machen wir das mit dem ipo
sein okay okay ist passt aber mal auf
wenn das ist nicht das ende dieser
geschichte
[Musik]
ein radler im markt merkt euch jetzt mal
folgendes datum
mai 2018 das ist der moment in dem jump
das atom abkommen mit dem iran
angekündigt und neue
wirtschaftssanktionen gegen diesen
angekündigt
[Applaus]
aber nicht nur das er kündigte auch
sekundär sanktionen gegen all jene
länder an die weiterhin mit dem iran
handel treiben würden mit anderen worten
in ein land nun iranischen er hat öl
kaufen möchte nun dann wird das sich mit
uncle sam auseinandersetzen müssen und
dies schließt auch die europäischen
union ein
manche länder wie zum beispiel china
haben bereits klargestellt dass sie
nicht aufhören und weiterhin erdöl aus
der medizin
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der zweitgrößte kunde der iran kündigte
eine reduktion der importe an aber ganz
aus erdöl aus dem land dollars
verzichten wollen sie dann bei auch
nicht trotzdem sieht alles danach aus
dass die eu-vorgaben paris genau
einhalten wird auch wenn sie eigentlich
keine große lust also über dieses thema
werden im nächsten video wenn wir den
iran aus der gleichung herausstreichen
bleibt ein offener posten über eine
ganze million personen im einkaufs buch
europas und dieser muss nun
irgendjemandem fällig werden bagdad
denn eines ist klar gesagt überhaupt
euro und raten mal der überglückliche
wäre hier als retter in die bresche zu
springen
genau unsere freunde aus trump drängt
saudi arabien seine ölproduktion zu
erhöhen
saudi arabien hat seine produktion
gerade um 600.000 barrel erhöht russland
um 200.000 macht zusammen 800.000 passt
es bleibt also immer noch ein defizit
von 200.000 pro partie und dämmert es
jetzt was passiert wenn man das angebot
an erdöl auf dem internationalen markt
produziert genau der ölpreis steigt
lasst uns noch mal einen blick auf das
team werfen wenn ihr aufmerksam watt
könnt ihr jetzt sehen dass gleich nach
dem kampf anfängen über die iran
sanktionen zu sprechen
der ölpreis auf 80 us dollar gestiegen
ist
mit anderen worten die sache sieht jetzt
wirklich gut aus für die spanische
wirtschaft
[Musik]
saudi arabien southern weltbank nimmt
ein darlehen in höhe von 11 milliarden
dollar
in der zwischenzeit gibt es zwei dinge
die wir behandeln erstens steht die
islamische republik iran am rande des
wirtschaftlichen zusammenbruchs
dies führt zu protesten sozialen unruhen
und einem autoritären regime das sich in
einer sehr unvorteilhaften lagen philipp
zweiter steht die große frage im raum
nötigen programms sanktionen weiter
einhalten
die debatte könnte heutzutage nicht
heiser sein die eu führt maßnahmen ein
um unternehmen vor den sanktionen donald
trumps gegen den iran zu schützen
die kernfragen lauten also glaubt ihr
dass er am anfang vom ende des regimes
stehen glaubt ihr dass die europäische
union weiterhin öl aus dem iran kaufen
wird wir würden gerne erfahren welche
theorien ihrer zu haben und in den
folgenden videos werden wir sehen wie
sehr sich diese mit unseren eigenen
decken vergessen in der zwischenzeit
nicht dass wir jede woche branchen
videos veröffentlichen
liegt also auf den knopf so dass gärten
symbol damit ihr immer einen nach
richtigen bekommst wenn wir ein update
veröffentlichen
wenn dir dieses video gefallen hat gibt
unter einem like daumen und nehmer
macht's gut
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]